- I get what I want and if you are a no,
I'm just gonna climb
over you and find my yes.
- The best advice that
I would have to pass
to the next generation of women,
and as I'm still learning it myself,
is to trust your gut and your light
and don't dim your light for anybody.
And no matter how many nos you get,
you look in the mirror and
you tell yourself, yes I can.
And you continue to push
forward no matter what.
That's what I have to say.
- Absolutely.
- Pay no attention to no.
I pay no attention to no at all.
In fact, if you let me tell
it, I've never heard no.
I've never heard no.
- To not let anyone break your spirit.
To try to remove the self
doubt as early as you can.
To support other women, to
surround yourself with mentors,
to seek out the smartest
people in the room
to be your mentors.
To listen, to learn, to stay hungry,
and to take every opportunity you can.
- To believe that you can do it.
And not do it ever in an angry way.
Don't be a woman trying to
be a man in a man's world.
Like, be a sister, lift
your other fellow girls up.
Be all about girl power and
just believe in yourself.
Resist, resist, and
your voice does matter.
- As someone once told me
when I got my job on The Today Show,
he said, today you could
be drinking the wine,
tomorrow you could be picking the grapes.
I think success comes and goes
and you have high points and
low points in your career,
and I think it's really
important how you treat people.
Because the same people who help you up
are going to catch you when you fall.
Kindness and compassion
should go hand in hand
with ambition and drive.
- To trust yourself.
To get grounded in your beliefs.
And to not doubt yourself.
- Believe in yourself to go forward
and to try to bring your
belief system to the world.
- I wish someone had said to
me, don't settle for less.
Or if they said that to me, I
wish I would have believed it.
Because it's true.